The color slice in the previous exercise gives a sense of the limits of what
colors can be displayed on your monitor. This is a different kind of color
space. We won't get heavily into this diagram, which shows what is called the
CIE XYZ color space. But I want to point out a few key bits. Along this curved
edge are the pure spectral colors. The values here are the wavelengths of light
that produce various colors. You can in fact, see the colors of the rainbow as
you move along it. Red, orange, yellow, green, blue and so on. You might also
notice a funny artifact along here and here. I find these lines will show up
more strongly if I look at my computer screen from a different angle. These
bands which are called Mach Bands are something you might run into every now and
then in computer graphics. It turns out that the pure spectral colors on this
outer rim are not something a monitor can actually display. The pixels in a
monitor each have a red, green and blue component, and none of these components
is a pure spectral color but rather a mix of differing wavelengths of light.
What this means is that our monitors have limits on the colors that they can
display. What is happening outside of these dashed lines is that the illustrator
is just faking it, by picking the best possible color and repeating it on out to
the edge of the curve. What the diagram of displayable colors looks like is
this. This triangle is called the device's color gamma. The vertices are the
same, RGB vertices we used to form our own color triangle. And there's a slice
out of the color cue. This whole area reminds me of seeing advertisements for
TVs on television. The announcer would talk about how their new TV's image was
brighter, sharper and with richer colors. On the screen they chose some bright,
crisp video. But of course I was seeing this video with my old TV, so there
wasn't much point in them showing me anything in the advertisement at all. The
key take-away in all this is that the RGB color's base is directly connected to
the monitor. And that monitors have limits as to what colors they can display.
The idea of a color gamut is also important in printing. For example, for
high-end printing, custom inks can be used to increase the extent of the gamut.